[Music]
OUP nasty yes
this boy was in some sort of a near
ocean point you might know something
about saltwater drowning right from
animal research studies in salt water
drowning you have water and plasma
pouring out of the blood into the lot
which makes the problem worse I think
he's just obstructing the upper air
certainly one problem that goes on then
we must move now quickly to the
intensive care unit where we can provide
the monitoring we'll have to get blood
gases
hélène spreader there is a difference in
treatment if we in saltwater and
freshwater
[Music]
it's not easy this anesthesiology story
patients here research there now if we
could emphasize patient cares related to
research I don't think we made that
point well enough Emily
you'll be the death of this office not
true I was having a dinner party and we
got on this subject and everyone was
fascinated you know they never really
thought much about it sleep and pain and
well that's why we're doing the article
I want to see I have a few questions do
we know what he's doing I don't know
that she's breathing like that's right I
suspect that she's breathing carbon
dioxide he is have you tried it
yourselves
that's everything
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you learn coming
with this apparatus we're studying for
the effects of slight increases inspired
carbon dioxide which fool the brain into
thinking the body is working hard so it
over breathe we're not studying hypoxia
at the moment but stock sale is less
oxygen than normal you get hypoxic
moderately hypoxic on the top of Pikes
Peak it pass out I wouldn't say so
[Music]
[Music]
could you decline unconsciousness what
is it
nobody knows nobody knows what keeps you
awake right now and how can aesthetics
put you to sleep
we do not understand what anesthesiology
is all about we don't understand the
state of anesthesia
well yes even now after 20 years and
seeing a patient go to sleep every
morning and injecting a drug that
completely paralyzes them it's a gnawing
experience I was on an airplane last
night and one woman didn't want to hear
any things about the fact that this man
had as a hatter all our lives in his
hands really well I sort of felt well
I'll be very happy when we land in
Philadelphia yeah I think people feel
the same way about anesthesia and that
you tinkered with a very significant
part of their brain for example right
eventually some chemical reaction must
take place which turns something off or
turn something on or changes something
not a cellular level but a molecular
level how does it do what it is doing
and that's related to this shape that
the molecule will assume in the body
what it means shape will it occupy this
particular shape or indeed will occupy
this one literally nobody knows at a
molecular level know what's going on and
what those anesthetic agents do what
we're really talking about is the
function of the human
what's going on inside how the
anesthetics change what's going on we
show them a study actually in progress
yet we'll say this is what you'll look
like you'll be on that table and a great
many of these people are willing to do
it people like to be right up against a
problems how's it feel
Stewart will feel numbness and tingling
the sounds will become louder
he's spinning down a long corridor
Stockton a himself has breathed this
mixture and knows exactly what these
feelings are it's a countdown when the
countdown reaches zero radioactive
Krypton is suddenly switched into the
breathing system is that a radioactive
tracer yes
the Krypton emits small amounts of
radioactivity which tell us how much
energy his brain cells are producing so
what do you think you'll be working on
next we would bring this massive amount
of equipment into the operating room we
have now been able to identify other
special problems in anesthesiology and
we see that these traditional drugs
really don't fit yes since the days of
chloroform about 20 additional
anesthetics have been given so powerful
that we've got to know from second to
second for the exact concentration that
the patient's breathing we found
recently that as soon as he went to
sleep his oxygen fell in essence it's
due to the anesthetic drugs and we take
constant sampling what we've done is to
establish a laboratory right in the
middle of an operating suite this brings
research techniques and that daily
availability Sephora's patients are
concerned this is one we
certainly is the notion that anesthesia
is something I can be improved used to
be paradoxical as a tattoo as it may
sound they they attitude just 15 years
ago was that that this was a fairly
simple procedure which could be carried
out by a dumbest intern and or a
technician for that matter being dumped
into anesthesia under those
circumstances not really knowing any
more any less than I than the rest of
the people horrified me so much that
that I think just had something to do
with with inferencing made towards
getting into the specialty myself
Vanessa just has an extraordinary
advantage then you say to study men and
to find out ways of relieving is various
symptoms in the clinical situation is
where you get the ideas for your next
research project it has a unique
feedback and that you can go back to the
laboratory with a host of ideas not only
for what is interesting to study next
but also about what is important to
study next the need for new agents
usually rises from one's bedside
experience yes of the interactions that
occur in patients between the medicines
other chemicals that they take from this
rather frenetic world in which we live
how these drugs interact with
anesthetics you know really when you're
anesthetized that simply is not enough a
surgeon requires a great deal more than
that in taking care of people the one
can see gee if I had a drug like this
that would be just what he would need
and the next step is to go to an organic
chemist say hey can it be made once we
get the drug we have to test it and it
gives us particular insight into the
mechanism alacrity we then study these
things in animals the animal is
anesthetized and we record the movements
of the muscles based on the stimulation
of the nerves and so you can see then
the decrease in muscle activity as a
result of this drug you can see the
twitch now recovering the drug is
wearing off isn't just research there
you are with a person and you have to do
something well yes the nerve stimulator
that we use in the laboratory has
spawned the blockade monitor that we use
in the operating room this allows us
then to monitor this particular growth
so we can have some idea as to the
profoundness of the effect and the time
scale as to when it is beginning to wear
off and that's very important in
anesthesia because you are different
from anybody else ever created each drug
therefore may well have a different
effect
as a different entity from him and
children one of the erroneous concepts I
think in terms of at least in the minds
of most laymen is that a child is a
miniature adult and nothing could be
further from the truth to give a
different dose with some muscle
relaxants I might give him a larger one
matter of fact what kind of operation so
you have to do on children well
sometimes the arteries will wrap around
the air passages and constrict them
sometimes the spine is born open this
has to be closed immediately to prevent
infection on the first day first day of
life yes can't imagine that a first day
baby like my brother's child they didn't
dare operate yes pediatric surgery is a
relatively new form of surgery it's only
been since the early 1940s that major
operations have been performed with
success on infants concentrating on
supporting the patient's life systems
you're practically breathing for him yes
understanding how he's breathing and
understanding how his heart is beating
or his brain is function is not just
putting him under well it became very
clear to me very soon after I began to
do anesthesia that preventing pain and
putting the patient asleep was only a
small part of what an anesthesiologist
did that a great deal of what he did was
keeping the patient alive during a very
critical period in the
his life that two three four hours that
he was being operated on what about
people outside of surgery we began to be
called in to handle patients who weren't
being operated on but who needed this
intensive kind of chance all part of the
same thing isn't different that's the
point that I like to get across what
would put people into intensive care
besides surge well you have the traffic
injury you have certain neuromuscular
diseases emphysema chronic bronchitis
many of the patients with heart failure
pointing out that you cannot separate
the function of the heart and function
of the loan and the thing is that if you
can't breathe for such an individual the
crucial thing about breathing is that
you have no reserves for oxygen at all
and so that your the minute you stop
breathing your pure brain becomes
inoperable due to lack of oxygen and and
dies in a matter of minutes
it's a recently we had a more
old-fashioned type of chest injury the
farmer was was charged by his pool and
he was unable to breathe for himself
getting better
[Music]
your jaws are still wired together what
was the last thing that you remember
about the bull how'd you feel when you
woke up I think the most immediately
striking thing about any intensive care
unit is that it contrasts with the
notion that most people have about a
hospital it looks anything but restful
yes you don't see a quiet comfortable
bedroom with nurses quietly moving
around it's a kind of place where the
nurses and physicians are living with
the patient and treating the patient on
a moment-to-moment basis then that means
that the place is equally active at
12:00 noon or at 4:00 midnight
little Tama sector we just operated on
them week ago he hasn't been in there
three weeks Thomas yes Thomas Peters had
a prolonged problem centering around
obstruction and his lower air passages
you see they still on a ventilator
because if we let him breathe on his own
he would very soon become exhausted and
die
yes this is the kind of youngster that
wouldn't survive without an intensive
care unit and a whole intensive care
philosophy the equipment and the means
just wouldn't be there then over here
he's a major heart problem it's a tiny
baby not normal yet in his breathing
the little one was born with a major
narrowing of his nasal passages still
needs to be watched carefully he looks
as if he's fighting it yet patients who
have respiratory disease do struggle our
research is to help us first decide when
a person is working too hard and when we
must take over by hand just by feel bad
you cared at hand but you have a face is
life at your fingertips very hard on you
emotionally
[Music]
and we know now that tragically many
patients are dying because they do not
get the benefit of care for lung disease
which is reversible and I think we have
curable disease that is not really being
treated and that's costly what's going
to keep her search going we had more
money we could expand our resources yes
may seem crass and when we were speaking
of human life to talking about money but
we have to face the fact that money is
human life in hospital if we had more
money with we could save more lives
where do we stand on government support
for research well Medical Research is a
very expensive proposition and just the
the instruments and the manpower they're
involved is something that no one
institution could possibly afford within
the National Institutes of Health the
National Institute of General Medical
Sciences was created to take care of the
general problems such as anesthesiology
that are important to many different
diseases
putting the funds into this sort of
thing in order to improve patient care
the the patient is the taxpayer
[Music]
so you've never gotten bored no not in
not in this kind of work how did you get
caught up in I had come from a
background that these days I suppose
would be classified as underprivileged
and was very fortunate indeed to be able
to go to college at all in the depths of
the Great Depression at that time a
whole new world of knowledge and culture
open that I never even knew existed I
thought in those days that I would stay
in the humanities and probably become a
professional philosopher as I looked
back on it was a exciting wonderful idea
I was leaving philosophy a mistake if
you think of the humanities as being in
place of hard science people are
complicated they require and need
somebody who really knows the scientific
facts also knows what he doesn't know
and brings compassion
the scale they learn anxiety even though
they don't relate pain to anxiety you've
heard the phrase scared to death this
has a good deal of scientific validity
well certainly when you go to the
bedside of a sick man or an injured man
you find tremendous anxiety I don't know
which is worse where the pain is worse
than nausea nausea is worse than pain
but they each one as it exists when it
exists is is dominating you can measure
it one can put numbers in front of front
of subjective items GSS or even daily
pain for years and also with nausea and
and and drowsiness you studied some
twenty subjective responses
now had we not made these observations
on patients who are receiving drugs we
certainly would never come up with that
concept my friends think of
anesthesiology is just a painkiller and
a put to sleep er it's no longer just
take away pain what is pain do you mean
we don't know well you saw of course the
four micropipettes which permit the
intracellular recording and also the
application of very very minut amounts
of drugs to study the mechanisms of pain
reaction of cells what else the other
area that we're looking into the
sociologic and psychological aspects of
pain trying to decide what are the
factors our pain clinic is really a
multidisciplinary facility whose goal is
to provide the environment to this team
of physicians to work in parallel rather
than to the patient goes to this fellow
and to this fellow in this fella in this
fellow and the only common bond is the
patient but you philia knows and me when
he's getting sharp again now you have
state pain pills
but I would say 15 to 17 a day I think I
figured out roughly taken between 2500
and 3000 6 months
I'm sure that comes from a variety
there does seem to be some relationship
the way that she shows her Pinker bring
her teeth but letting you know she
really hurts anyway
with love and devotion and gratitude to
this president she commented too that if
it weren't for the back pain and things
were now comfortable enough so that they
could be having
she is a 53 year old housewife who came
to us about a year ago complaining of
low back pain is the pain there all the
time
No
to the side he has my father
anything else big painless so I didn't
get into it at all because I have to
keep on boys
[Applause]
yes I found a new place to buy what I
wanted didn't supervise doll the loogie
and everything that you you were doing
all of the moving I supervised knowledge
myself bought the house so the other one
get all a man G myself my husband
continued to work every day so he didn't
have to
that's been my understanding that this
is kind of the way you do things is that
you take much of the responsibility I
like responsibility I always did
[Music]
this has been the case for most of your
life all my life has been the case right
didn't look to you to rely on I started
working it said when I was seven years
old what did you do then I pick cotton
that's right
save my money and bought myself a pair
of red goose shoes
just beautiful was that your first pair
of new shoes no it was my first pair of
reduced and rusty shoes I see have
worked before bedroom home get all the
gardening all the yard work and work 40
hours a week until I hurt my back and
how did that change things and all
everything is completely changed
I think anyone who says I heard I'm in
pain I think that it is an emotional
experience total experience this is
clearly one of the major problems of our
age levels of perception of just about
everything things that are very hard to
define but they are all related to
consciousness in some way presumably if
if one could halt the degradation of the
body which is going on every instant and
to suspended totally and then reactivate
it again on another planet then we could
afford to spend literally years in terms
of space travel
I suppose the anesthesiologist will be
the specialist really long space travel
maintaining us delicate
factors there must be a certain amount
of what I call productive leisure for
contemplation and study as director of
the National Institute of from a general
medical scientist how do you buy brains
I've never been able to buy brains and
I'm not sure anyone else does really you
can buy a certain high-grade skill but
you don't buy brains I'm convinced what
brings a good man into the field
well the excitement of being able to
develop new information and new
knowledge
and it's particularly gripping when
clinical research is involved to
anticipate where trends are going to
develop is very much as if one is
writing a surfboard just within the past
moving curl of the way
the crowning point of the whole series
of experiments perhaps involving years
of time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you